[Music]
in anti dine-and-dash news fuck'em
submitted by Bart's friend oh hello
he's an avenue friend I do your family
we're like fast and furious funny today
family I know you just got a family got
40 other times that means you should
punch Bart more often I know this
morning she punched him and broke his
nose or something like me really that's
why she's shocked today we did your your
culture this morning we're Thai oh oh
you're practicing I thought y'all were
just like arguing okay like actually
well that's your culture too but yeah my
parents argue a lot like a [ __ ] stay
together and be unhappy for me a
restaurant is ordered to pay ten
thousand dollars after a group of black
people were asked to prepay for their
food what way well it was fast food a
restaurant that's do you think that's
restaurants no I just I was just I was
just saying like that's what you always
exactly a dining restaurant these black
people came in and like they with the
Denny's and they're like can you play
and they were like pay first before how
do you pay before you eat they probably
ordered and then they were like okay pay
now I mean do they do they have a
epidemic of black people coming in and
running out after they eat of something
kind of Chinese food
what kind of the Chinese good plays Oh
mark is it and it was like a mom-and-pop
shop or like a chain I feel like Asians
also they're not very PC they don't know
what PC is so whatever insecurity or
whatever thought that they have they
just executed if they're like the last
three customers that did a [ __ ] dine
and dash was Mexican from this point on
every single Mexican which we asked them
to do that well dude what's crazy you
know what even even at my family's
restaurant one time we had we just hired
this waitress and she was like kind of
like she was you know she was super Thai
you know I'm saying barely spoke any
shoes super dye and in my boys super
high
and then Rick and my boy Chris like like
because most of my homies from high
school were black you know something
like they were coming over after school
and boy Rick and my boy Chris they were
coming over and this waitress this new
waitress she goes and she locks the door
before they before they walked in and
they were throw eggs and they were like
and I'm like these are my friends and my
dad had to like like yell at her like
eight what does she ever do that
she just she felt bad you know she was
just like oh stop some get robbed or
something I guess because it was it was
also like it was that night and she was
like she was like nervous she has like a
chart of skin color she goes and you
know that's asian star right there
she's just kind of like she was she was
you know scared obligor what do you
think they've learned that because my
grandma was not scared of black people
at all mm-hm and until like well we
lived in a bad area and then some black
kids were playing a prank and then
through some [ __ ] at her like some
bottles of like drink or whatever and
from that point on
she got really scared I don't know where
that girl could've learned it maybe just
you know media and [ __ ] I mean what do
you really like watching the movie my
parents owned a beauty supply store so
when black people came in it was awesome
right but you know of course cuz like if
you if you grew up you know like of
course we grew up in that neighborhood
super diverse so it's like new way like
you know anybody that grew up there
would never be like oh my god black
people are here lock the doors you know
I'm saying but she was like coming from
Thailand never probably even seen a
black dude right like in real life
there's some black ties though Thai
people get really dark yes yes they do
yes we do
Muay Thai [ __ ] yeah okay that
guy's dark yeah there were definitely
times in Thailand where I would be like
we'd be driving and then like we're on
the freeway and we saw these two dudes
on a motorcycle and I was like oh it's
like blackness in Thailand's cool I got
to see that in a while and they were
just there just I just really tense I
gots it yeah yeah so this restaurant
here this takes place in Toronto and so
they asked this group of people to
prepay their food and so once they heard
that they're like wait what this doesn't
sound right so
they started asking other diners around
them like hey were you asked to pay for
prepaid for your food and a lot of
people obviously said no so then that's
when they sued mmm the restaurant was
ordered to pay $10,000 by Ontario's
Human Rights Tribunal you know it's
funny because Asians are so [ __ ]
openly racist they probably get sued
and/or like before they even got sued
they ask them why did you do this and
they go because they are black and I'm
afraid they're gonna spew yeah with a
matter of fact yeah they're like oh yeah
but that's crazy because Toronto so
diverse you know saying like tight and
they're also very like all about being
inclusive way more liberal than we are
yes that's weird that that business with
their fobs though I mean the toraat like
you know like the restaurant owners you
know they they don't know this [ __ ] like
you know fobs are not gonna there's
super Asian like when I was younger now
I bring my friends over when I have like
friends are a little bit large
my mom would purposely give them like
way less food and I'm my mom that's
[ __ ] why are you doing they go and
it's just openly it's like a matter of
fact like you're obviously you're fat
and you need to be on a diet
there would have been a patient on my
plate dude that's just a sliver it's
just a [ __ ] cup of water so you're
not getting nothing
there were times whenever Rick comes
over in my moans I was like one time
specifically came over my mom like has
his big ass she has his Apple she's like
ray he's either Apple even more even
more vicious it's like it was a huge
that was like thank you okay I will I
was like like he doesn't know he needs
to like diet and exercise you know it
takes your side you owe me that hurt my
feeling real Todd I came to chill in
your mommy [ __ ] me yeah it's what they
knew it's so funny because it's just
it's not the goodness of their heart
it's your best friend so she's like I
care about this kid like it's my own so
I gotta give him this Apple keeps the
doctor away
yeah remember your mom I was just
chilling on the pool she got up out of
her chair walked all around the pool
came over to sneeze it JA why you so fat
and she walked away yeah you know what
so lazy I was in tears crying laughing
because of this fools reaction he's
chillin like in like this floaties right
like this she goes everyone's minding
their own business
probably everyone got food coma in the
afternoon people are just chilling
people take a nap sunglasses know she
was doing her own thing she yeah she got
up and and went all around
I watched her too cuz she was staring at
me and smiling the whole time so I
thought she was gonna say something
pleasant or something and she goes down
and she's like you're so fat like so
late like everyone's lazy what am I
supposed to be doing playing basketball
or like doing my taxes like what gilja p
yeah like lazy like am i supposed to be
working damn that's so funny you are
pretty late how do they how do they grow
up like that you know I'm saying like
not doesn't that had like snow feel to
you cuz even like even my dad who's like
super like you know I speak English to
my dad he's like he's chill in like
he'll like I'll just be chilling
sometimes when I started getting late
and he's just just grabbed my so much
crap hits me like it's like Oh what's
this could you could you not did I get
hurt so you know like I know it's there
I just had like this realization
yesterday about your mom right I was
chilling and because when I was in
[ __ ] st. Louis there's this dude
that's a he really practices Buddhism
right and then your mom is also hardcore
Buddhist - yeah but the way she acts
it's hella anti Buddhist - I get hurt me
like that oh cool a second if she's so
why should she do that [ __ ] it's so
[ __ ] funny it doesn't make sense
who doesn't like not controlling yeah
she's like the opposite she's trying to
control but at the same time she's
hardcore Buddhist yeah yeah it's about
being tolerant like everything's okay
like I could accept
and then later on that day she ends up
separating hearing your dad because your
debt her dad was crying cuz he's happy
they just got married she's like no no
she's trying to intervene and control
everything yeah it's pretty funny and
then she tries to move our industry ins
like we bucket whoosh oozes ass away and
squeeze it and still somehow good
hilarious and Buddhist fat yeah Buddhist
all fat happy Buddha anyways yeah I mean
you know they got the skinny one with
like though like the starving one and
then he said I can't take it no mo
what's the point of life if you're just
gonna suffer all day let's eat and be
happy yeah so back to this story here so
this is a meal and this is long she the
restaurant behind it Oh Hong Shi oh that
his name's Emile yeah you're saying this
is a meal like that's what they serve if
you write here's a whole meal maybe she
got offended because he said her name he
Talia making fun of her I'm a meal yeah
right big guy
see you flow with me huh yeah get out of
here okay you think you are smack he
kind of looks Asian to what the [ __ ] a
little bit even look like he's mixed
yeah he kind of looks around legends
brother bro saleh ali work muscle holla
I'm making him named uh what was the
restaurants do they have Ursula it is
[ __ ] statements like that I want you
anticipate he's black beer so the only
the only female happy said was this
quote I'm sowwy okay
I try not to doing this time don't give
it one-star yelp anymore please they
said we are deeply concerned about the
situation and the people affected there
are a number of sensitivities and
considerations about the situation and
for that reason the tribunal outcome is
under appeal by legal risk
representatives at this time we cannot
comment further beyond emphasizing that
the current data right that she
dedicated to be committed inclusive and
responsible members of the community
because he's saying that it was a
previous owner
you know they're not gonna learn
anything you're just gonna have a sign
on says outside that says no black
people about too many a lawsuit oh my
god yeah you're never gonna learn
they're just just one problems and that
is another part I mean you were saying
it was a different owner when that
happened oh so they sold the restaurant
no it just means like a dad we're
running it now the dad's owner it's true
though like it's kind of weird like how
how like this culture learns that type
of thing because you got to realize when
Asian immigrants come here they don't
have any notions of what goes on they
don't know what yes I knew that [ __ ] is
ya know so I wonder what who taught him
that right yeah and that's the thing I
always worry about and that's like the
thing that's like the weird part like
there's like this set type of racism in
this country that seeps into people who
come here because they're blank slates
like all the [ __ ] they go down I don't
know [ __ ] you know people are just
people
[Music]